SEVERAL CHILDREN NEEDED TO GO TO
THE HOSPITAL.
JULIE?
>> Julie: THANK YOU.
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT IN
THE MEANTIME AND ISSUING AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER WITH THE
TRANSPORT OF MIGRANTS WHO POSE A
RISK OF CARRYING COVID INTO
TEXAS COMMUNITIES.
ABBOTT IS SLAMMING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOR ALLOWING
COVID POSITIVE MIGRANTS TO MOVE
AROUND FREELY WHILE HITTING
AMERICANS WITH NEW RULES.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CARES MORE ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT RESIDENTS OF AMERICA THAN HE
DOES OF THE RESIDENTS OF
AMERICA.
BECAUSE HE HAS ONE STANDARD
TRYING TO MASK UP AND VACCINATE
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS BY ALLOWING
FREE PASS INTO THE UNITED STATES
OF PEOPLE WITH A HIGH
PROBABILITY OF COVID AND THEN
SPREADING THAT COALBED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES HAS BEEN SHOWN AND
ITS DEADLY AND DANGEROUS.
THEY MUST BE STOPPED.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A
TALKING TO US THIS MORNING.
THERE ARE VERY LARGE GROUPS,
BACK-TO-BACK, 845 MIGRANTS
ENCOUNTERED IN JUST A 24-HOUR
PERIOD IN RIO GRANDE VALLEY.
AND THESE COVID CASES CONTINUE
TO POUR IN.
>> WE’VE NEVER SEEN THIS TYPE OF
MIGRATION INTO OUR STATE AND
OBVIOUSLY WITH COVID EXPOSURE,
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE DEADLY
FOR OUR CITIZENS.
SO IT’S HARD TO UNDERSTAND WHY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS SO
FOCUSED ON STOPPING THE SPREAD
OF COVID WITH MASKS AND MANDATES
AND VACCINATION AND YET THEY
HAVE OPENED OUR BORDER UP AND
ARE TELLING PEOPLE THAT IT’S
BASICALLY OKAY TO, AND HERE WE
ARE.
WE GOT THE SPREAD OF COVID TO
GOING ON A GREATER RATE THAN WE
DID JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO.
IT’S REALLY IRRESPONSIBLE AND
DANGEROUS FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE THIS
PRACTICE.
>> THIS IS CALLED THE GA 37,
IT’S GOING TO RESTRICT GROUND
TRANSPORTATION FOR MIGRANTS THAT
POSE A RISK OF POSSIBLY CARRYING
CORONAVIRUS INTO THESE TEXAS
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS OF COURSE
INCREDIBLY UNFAIR.
HOW SEVERE OF A PUNISHMENT WILL
THERE BE TO THOSE WHO DON’T
ABIDE BY THIS RULE AND HOW
EFFECTIVE OF ITS TORRENT DO YOU
BELIEVE THIS TO BE?
>> I APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR
DOING THIS, HE’S DOING
EVERYTHING HE CAN DONATE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING
AGAINST US BUT WHAT THAT HAS
ALLOWED THE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DO IS
BASICALLY STOP PEOPLE THAT THEY
ARE SUSPICIOUS HAVE COME ACROSS
IN VIOLATION OF STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW WHO MIGHT HAVE COVID
AND BASICALLY SEND THEM BACK TO
THE BORDER.
SO IT’S NO GREAT PUNISHMENT,
THEY ARE JUST BEING SENT BACK TO
THE BORDER AND PUSHED THROUGH
THE POINT OF ENTRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DON’T STAY IN OUR
STATE AND EXPOSE PEOPLE
POTENTIALLY TWO MORE COVID.
>> WHAT MAKES THIS SO MUCH WORSE
IS THAT THOSE THAT ARE DETAINED
ARE RELEASED, SO I DON’T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE POINT IS OF
DETAINING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
REPUBLICANS TORCHING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THERE’S A
REPORT OUT THAT STATES THAT
50,000 MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
RELEASED WITHOUT COURT DATES AND
THEY ARE LITERALLY JUST
DISAPPEARING INTO THIN AIR INTO
THE U.S. AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
OUTSIDE OF TEXAS WITH ONLY 13%
OF THEM APPEARING TO THE ICE
OFFICIALS THAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED
TO MEET.
>> WE’VE TAKEN AN AMAZING STEP
BACK, THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
PEOPLE WERE RELEASED AND KNEW
THAT THEY DIDN’T HAVE A HEARING
FOR YEARS AND NEVER SHOWED UP
AGAIN.
EVERYBODY KNEW BASICALLY, NOW WE
ARE BACK TO THAT SAME POLICY.
I DON’T HAVE TO STAY IN MEXICO
WHERE THEY DISAPPEARED INTO THE
COUNTRY BUT NOW, WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE THAT STOMACH MOST PEOPLE
ARE GOING.
>> Julie: THE TWEETS ON THE
WALL, IF WE CAN PUT THEM BACK TO
SEE HOW DUMB I COULD SHOW HOW IT
RAGED, THEY SHOULD BE EQUALLY
OUTRAGED CALLING IT UTTERLY
LAWLESS AND COMPLETELY ASININE
AND SHAMEFUL.
YOU BELIEVE THIS IS PREDICTABLE?
THIS IS THAT PREDICTABLE CRISIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE KNEW FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHAT DIDN’T WORK
AND TRUMP HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS
FOR FOUR YEARS AND INSTITUTING
POLICIES LIKE COVERT
RESTRICTIONS, MAKING SURE
CRIMINALS WERE NOT RELEASED OUT
OF PRISON INTO OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY.
AND MAKING SURE THEY HAD TO STAY
IN MEXICO, ALL OF THEM HAD BEEN
PUSHED ASIDE KNOWING HOW THAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
WE KNEW THAT THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN AND THIS WAS PREDICTABLE,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANTS
THIS TO HAPPEN AND THEY WANTED
TO HAPPEN KNOWING THAT SPREAD OF
COVID WILL BE GREATER.
>> Julie: AT THE WHITE HOUSE
IS STILL BLAMING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND YOU JUST
TOUCHED ON THAT.
THIS HAS BEEN AN ISSUE SINCE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BEHIND THE
BORDER CRISIS, THAT’S REALLY A
BORDER CHAOS, AS IT RELEASES ITS
PLAN TO DEAL WITH THE ROOT
CAUSES NOW.
THAT’S COMING JUST NEARLY TWO
MONTHS AFTER PRESIDENT
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS’ VISIT TO
GUATEMALA AND FIVE MONTHS INTO
HER ROLE AT THIS POINT AS THE
PERSON ON THE CRISIS.
SHE WAS OPPOSED BY THE ROOT OF
THE BECAUSE WHEN SHE VISITED
GUATEMALA TWO MONTHS AGO.
SO THE PLAN INCLUDED ADDRESSING
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY, TACKLING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AMONG OTHER
ISSUES, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY ABOUT
THIS PLAN OF THE WHITE HOUSE IS
FINALLY PUTTING FORWARD?
>> I DON’T THINK IT’S GOING TO
WORK, IT WILL TAKE YEARS TO
FIGURE OUT THE ROOT CAUSE.
THESE ARE RULES THAT DIDN’T WORK
BEFORE AND SO TO BLAME THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THEY KEEP TALKING
ABOUT SCIENCE AS IT RELATES TO
COVID BUT WHY DON’T THEY JUST
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS?
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS AND HOW MANY
IMMIGRANTS WE HAD COMING IN, AND
THERE’S NO DOUBT THAT THE CHANGE
IN POLICY THAT THEY THINK IS
MULTIPLE TIMES WORSE.
>> Julie: AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
BLAME THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WHEN THE PROBLEMS WERE THERE FOR
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WHICH
IS A LESSON THAT SHOULD BE
LEARNED BY ALL POLITICIANS, THE